afternoon I'm Matthew Spalding associate
vice president and Dean of educational
programs for Hillsdale College in
Washington DC
welcome to the Allen P Kirby Center for
Constitutional studies in citizenship
Hillsdale College is an independent
institution of higher learning founded
in 1844 by men and women grateful to God
for the blessings of liberty and
believing that the diffusion of
education is essential to its perpetuity
and so for 170 years rejecting any
government funding Hillsdale College has
provided education in the liberal arts
to students regardless of race creed or
color the purpose of this Kirby Center
in Washington DC is to extend the
college's mission to the nation's
capital by teaching students citizens
and political leaders about the
principles and practice of American
constitutionalism and how to understand
and apply those principles in today's
politics in doing so we seek to promote
and promote not policies or partisanship
but a statesmanship worthy of American
liberty the idea of sound principles and
the challenge of their application the
reality of current politics defines
today's speaker I first got to know Paul
Ryan when he was within senator Sam
Brownback after having been a
speechwriter for vice presidential
nominee Jack him soon thereafter he ran
for his home congressional district in
Wisconsin one and has represented
Wisconsin's first congressional district
since 1999 a fifth-generation Wisconsin
native his Hina's wife Janna live in
Janesville Wisconsin with their three
children
Liza Charlie and Sam representative Ryan
is a leading policy voice in the public
debate especially on budget and fiscal
matters he is now chairman of the House
Budget Committee as a senior member of
the House Ways and Means Committee his
first budget plan the road Mac roadmap
for America's future remains the
centerpiece of Republican budget
thinking serious in his faith he is also
a prominent and passionate voice for
welfare reform and conservative policy
solutions unsatisfied with the status
quo he believes we have a moral
obligation to elevate the condition of
men and lift artificial weights from all
shoulders as Lincoln once played because
of all these things that should come as
no surprise that in 2012 he was the
Republican nominee for vice president at
this rate he what might well make
something of himself the future but it's
overriding concern today and the context
in which all these reforms must take
place is constitutional self-government
a topic he will address in his remarks
day on renewing the American idea please
join me in welcoming Representative Paul
Ryan
Oh
it's fantastic
thank you what a beautiful place I've
got to say I Matt and I have been
friends for a long time and I want to
thank you Matt for your invitation here
at Hillsdale at the Kirby Center I
people here I have been reading the
lectures coming from Hillsdale and in
Primus since my early 20s and I've just
got to say how indispensable and how
invaluable Hillsdale is to the cause of
the American idea and thank you for
doing that thank you
you know you might think it's a little
late to give an Independence Day address
but New York their delegates to the
Continental Congress they didn't adopt
the Declaration of Independence
until July 15th so I think I'm
fashionably late or as the New Yorkers
say right on time
indeed this topic is always timely
that's because the Declaration of
Independence will always be the defining
statement of the American idea and it's
the greatest political statement of
human Liberty ever written it's a safe
to say statement everyone knows the
story of how the American Revolution was
difficult and a desperate struggle we
forget in hindsight just how unlikely it
was that they would succeed many times
defeat seemed all but inevitable many
despaired yet that small band of
patriots statesmen achieved victory
against a long-established and seemingly
unlimited ruler of seemingly unlimited
power they did so by remaining dedicated
to America's cause into each other
fighting hard at every turn knowing that
their success or failure might determine
whether they or any people would ever
fight again for the great purpose of
governing themselves in the past our
nation has survived trials prospered and
endured and so has our Liberty I believe
we're in a great period of trial again
yet I'm confident that we can survive
prosper endure for many more generations
but all of this depends
as it did in the spring of 1776 or the
fall of 1864 the end of 1941 on what we
do and how we act to shape the course of
events on the surface the problem seems
obvious we have a president who treats
the rule of law more like a rule of
thumb but look more closely and you'll
see the problem isn't this president or
at least not only this president when he
leaves office there will be plenty of
other candidates like him - ready to
take his spot and he's done all he's
done is he is empowered and embolden a
certain governing philosophy one that is
at odds with our founding principles and
this philosophy is gaining ground by the
day
the point is our opponents see politics
as a long-term project and so should we
I want to argue today that in everything
we do in every policy we propose we need
to renew the American idea conservatism
is not about the past it's not some
misty eyed nostalgia for a world that
has come and gone and it's not a
skittish disposition to merely just go
it slow or tinker around the edges nor
is conservatism about blind opposition
to government for sure government today
is too big bureaucratic inefficient and
unaccountable but we must not jettison
the very rule of law that shields our
Liberty no conservatism is about
conserving something principles that are
timeless because they are true to be
renewed and applied in our time what is
the American idea well in short it is
self-government under the rule of law
the American idea is rooted in our
respect for the rights with which we are
each endowed a respect that shapes
society where every person can work hard
achieve success in advance in life why
is this idea so special well for most of
human history a very different idea
reign supreme the idea that people are
fundamentally different some are born to
rule
others to obey almost all where subjects
are serfs shorn of all distinction and
firmly stuck in their places
the founders rebelled against this idea
they said everyone is created equal they
have an inalienable rights that come
from God and government is legitimate
only if it secures these rights the
founders were the first to take these
self-evident truths and put them into
practice they were the first to tell the
world and prove by their example that
the best government rests upon the
consent of the governed it wasn't easy
their first attempt the Articles of
Confederation failed so instead they
wrote a new constitution that both
strengthened in limited the federal
government it gave Congress enough power
to pass laws for the common good but it
also gave the president and the courts
the power to push back when Congress
tried to do too much and vice versa the
very structure of our federal government
was a vindication of self-government
three branches would control each other
so none of them would control the people
limiting government and freeing up the
associations of civil society would make
safety and security self-government and
liberty comfort and prosperity
accessible to everyone so in addition to
our birth certificate
the founders gave us a blueprint for a
free society a set of unchanging
principles as well as a framework of
government for a growing nation but it
wasn't just a set of abstract ideas or
just a procedural code of law our
declaration and our Constitution define
nothing less than a way of life for a
people a free people of good character
who would labor for themselves their
families and communities grateful to the
divine source of their rights and
committed to providing the blessings of
liberty to their posterity the framers
themselves disagreed about many
particulars in the Constitution no
sooner had it gone into effect than they
added the Bill of Rights each generation
struggled with different issues could
Congress create a bank
could the president by Louisiana could
the federal government build roads and
bridges but there was one thing on which
they all agreed the Constitution was our
guide and the Declaration was our North
Star and the Constitution endured
because it allowed prudent statesmen to
make wise decisions that preserved
self-government under the rule of law
there was one great failure slavery but
it wasn't a failure of the Constitution
it was a failure of statesmanship many
of the founders knew that slavery was
wrong but since they couldn't end it
there and then they wrote a constitution
that would allow a future generation to
do so unfortunately for decades
thereafter frightened politicians in
both the north and the south kicked the
can down the road Abraham Lincoln on the
other hand saw the solution not to
depart from but to return to the
principles of the Declaration and the
Constitution in the struggle of the
Civil War
the declaration defined the high ground
and a constitution proved powerful
enough to reunite a shattered nation
cleansed with three post-war amendments
the Constitution emancipated and offered
citizenship to millions and having
endured for over a hundred years the
Constitution became a victim of its own
success
as our cities grew more crowded and our
economy more prosperous and
unpredictable some came to believe that
the Constitution was obsolete and so for
the first time they said we needed a
wholesale change the founding project
was over they argued and the age of
administration had begun this new age
called for a living Constitution one
whose meaning did not rest on fixed
principles but changed according to the
winds and the whims of time in this
progressive vision self-government had
to give way to technical expertise to
professional bureaucrats governing
according to their centralized plans the
founders believed in the ability of men
and women
govern themselves and they distrusted
unchecked power which is why they
limited government and promoted a robust
civil society in the first place
progressives think it's better to govern
men and they seek a much larger and more
active central government that reaches
further and further into our lives
unfortunately through fits and starts
over the course of the 20th century the
progressive approach has become a
mindset at the heart of the Democratic
Party just as it has clouded Republican
thinking as well this is a core problem
that we face today the American idea has
not been rejected far from it and the
progressive contra vision has never
commanded a settled majority Americans
embrace some programs first championed
by progressives but they reject others
they accept many aspects of modern
government while still insisting on
their rights and constitutional forms
they have never consented to be ruled by
experts and they object to government
micromanaging their lives so this raises
basically a question how do we proceed
well we must begin by recognizing
practical reality but always move
sometimes coaxing sometimes pushing
toward the enduring principles to which
we are dedicated maneuvering in the sea
of politics we are forced to tack but
always guided by and steering toward our
fixed North Star self-government under
the rule of law is the conservative
touchstone it rests upon human equality
in our equal endowment with fundamental
rights it helps us identify measures
that conform to the American idea and
those that we can or conflict with the
American idea that's our guide for
reform here's a practical distinction
there's a difference in principle a very
clear bright line between two kinds of
government programs on the one hand
there are those that can be repaired and
restructured within the bounds of
limited government let's review those
and as we choose let's reform them even
upgrade them making them more efficient
through market
more decentralized and transparent more
fiscally sound and more true to
self-government but there are also many
programs of government that are defined
by massive bureaucracies intended to
direct large segments of our society in
our economy
these programs are centrally directed
they consist of arbitrary regulations
and directives that increase uncertainty
and insecurity and replace popular
government by bureaucratic rule it's a
hodgepodge of boards and commissions
with uncertain responsibilities and
unaccountable decision-making this way
of governing creates relationships
between government and money that
encourage cronyism and breed political
corruption
more and more Americans see this more
and more Americans are right to see
these programs as threat to their
freedom their well-being and their right
to self-government this whole approach
is irreconcilable with the American idea
and it must be rejected the American
idea imposes a duty to oppose those
programs which subvert popular
government and impose administrative
rule these programs in their
administrative forms leading examples
being Obamacare and the dodd-frank
financial apparatus cannot be reformed
or restructured but must be ended and if
we choose replaced by something
completely different and consistent with
popular consent and self-government no
reform is possible without recognizing
this problem no reform is worth pursuing
that does not turn against this rule and
take us down the path toward principled
renewal now the progressives were right
about something the country was crying
out for national safety net especially
in light of the Great Depression the
people agreed that we should pool our
resources to protect hard-working
families and yes they wanted smart
talented people to run the federal
government but they didn't want those
smart talented people to run their lives
they wanted to enlist the federal
government in the service of
self-government they didn't want to turn
over the keys but progressives didn't
pick up on those niceties once they got
their foot in the door they stayed and
they grew
and they grew first there was the New
Deal than the fair deal than the Great
Society and in 2008 they saw what they
thought was what they thought was
another great opening this was their
chance to cement their philosophy in the
place they say everything they've done
in the past five years is a logical
extension of a safety net if you liked
Medicare
you're gonna love Obamacare but it
hasn't quite worked out that way instead
the people have been resisting in the
left the left is baffled why support the
safety net but not progressivism here's
the difference everybody understands the
safety net and everybody benefits from
it take Social Security we all know how
it works or at least how it's supposed
to work when you're working you pay in
when you're retired it pays out same
thing for Medicare simple
straightforward everybody gets old
everybody gets sick and everybody
contributes in exchange for a routier
for for a secure retirement most people
think that's a fair trade and I agree
that's the opposite of the Affordable
Care Act nobody understands it everybody
is anxious if you listen to the sales
pitch it seems simple enough
every business with over 50 full-time
employees must offer health insurance
period or maybe not maybe you can get a
delay or a waiver or an exemption how do
you get one nobody knows the
administration makes changes on the fly
and the law changes almost every day
under the ACA an autonomous board called
the Independent Payment Advisory Board
decides what kind of care people in
Medicare will have in the future
bureaucrats are calling the shots and
they're running the show take dodd-frank
some say it's like deposit insurance but
deposit insurance protects the little
guy
dodd-frank on the other hand protects
the big guys that is the biggest most
powerful financial institutions in the
country and the result the result is
predictable big banks get bigger and
small banks get fewer more insidious is
that this law vastly expands these
bureaucrats power to simply take over
the
daily operations of any large financial
institution they deemed to be in trouble
so you can understand the skepticism in
short the difference between the safety
net and progressivism is the difference
between fair play and playing favorites
you see the safety net jives was self
government
and progressive bureaucracy does not the
one gives people more control over their
lives while the other takes it away and
there's a key principle at work here
the reason you have more control is
because you earned it you paid in you
made the difference that's the very
heart of self-government we the people
are the masters of our own fate we can
improve our lot by dint of our own
efforts and by working together of our
own free will
nobody has to force us or oversee us
earned success and earned security go
hand in hand don't get me wrong
everything wasn't all hunky-dory until
this president arrived Social Security
and Medicare were going broke they've
been going broke for years politicians
made promises that they couldn't keep
and now the bill is about to come do we
conservatives must be committed to
strengthening these programs because
that's what hardworking taxpayers have
earned and it's what they have made
clear in election after election limited
government with popular consent is the
principle that we are trying to uphold
here every idea I have proposed in this
area give people more control over their
future they paid in all of these years
so that they would have health insurance
why not let them choose their health
insurance more choice means more control
more control means more freedom the
argument for conservatism isn't that
it's more efficient it's the heart of
self-government and the problem with
progressivism isn't that it's just more
expensive the problem is that it
undermines self-government that's the
difference and that's a key distinction
one that we need to keep in mind because
there's another fallacy that is popular
just as some think anything government
does wrong others think anything
business does is right but in fact there
are two sides of the same coin both big
government and big business like to
stack the deck in their favor and though
there are sometimes adversaries there
are far too often allies bureaucrats
prefer to work with the big boys instead
of the upstarts that they don't know
they're more predictable and easier to
control
so government tips the scales in their
favor instead of letting competition
sort things out and big business like
business can become a willing accomplice
because regulation keeps the competition
out many times they don't oppose new
regulations instead they help write new
regulations the point is this crony
capitalism isn't a side effect it's a
direct result of big government and you
can see the results that work throughout
our economy it used to be only that the
success stories or the household names
now the failures are household names
Solyndra Fisker Tesla and businessman
they don't spend all of their time
hustling in the marketplace they spend
more and more their time hustling in
Washington both businessmen and
bureaucrats take part in this culture of
double standards take the Internal
Revenue Service it tells every family
that they have to keep seven years of
their tax records in case they're
audited yet they cannot keep six months
worth of their own emails it's a
disgrace neither the founders of America
nor of free-market economics would
recognize in this stratified system a
system a truly open market of Commerce
it isn't open it is an equal and
opportunity and it isn't producing
equitable profit growth or hope for
those at the bottom of the ladder it
isn't driven by satisfying the needs of
people but by experts calculus wealth
and preference you know my friend
congressman jeb Hensarling he's recently
launched a great challenge against the
crony capitalist economy in particular
against one of its manifestations the
export-import bank but the bank is just
one example of how bureaucratic
government is corrupting free enterprise
through and through
conservatives must stop defending this
cronyism is the progressives project for
economic control let them defend it
finally there is the temptation to ask
the courts to reap to intervene and
solve our problems for us some
conservatives think of judges the way
progressives think of bureaucrats
technical experts with the solutions to
our constitutional conflicts but judges
like bureaucrats are often the problem
we must be mindful of this temptation it
is true that the Supreme Court can be an
ally in conflicts surrounding the
Constitution but it can also be an
adversary under our Constitution of
self-government
the court that really counts is the
court of public opinion we can't simply
rely on the court the Supreme Court
alone to defend our rights we have to
remember at the end of the day the court
of public opinion where the American
people hand down their verdict on
Election Day is the final arbiter in
popular government the people are the
final judge and jury and to come full
circle we must never forget that a
people who claim the right of
self-government those people are always
on trial this country began as a people
on trial out of our first trial in the
Revolutionary era we adopted the
greatest most enduring constitution ever
written
we were tried in civil war in world wars
and depressions and inflation and we
survived and we prospered every effort
to take self-government away from our
people has been defeated so far will we
prevail again nothing in history is
inevitable there are no shortcuts or
silver bullets if we are to get through
our current problems as we have done in
the past we must do it by our own wits
in our own efforts in this sense the
Constitution is not a living document so
much as a life-giving document it gives
purpose and direction to our way of life
as a free people let us remain committed
to the American idea with the inherent
good sense of the American
people we can we must and I believe we
will get through these trials together
freer and stronger than ever before
thank you very much
as cliche
we have time for some questions for reps
a new Ryan and I believe there are some
microphones if you would use those
please question back here in the back
hello congressman it's a son
Edie Turner with the fund for American
Studies here in Washington within the
last year you reached an agreement with
your counterpart in the Senate senator
patty Murray helps out working out
actually I think it's working out fairly
well we have we will have done eight
appropriation bills in the house the
main benefit of that agreement is we
brought the power of the purse back to
Congress for three years all we did was
punch to the administration said you go
run the bills here's a continuing
resolution now we're actually going
through the actual line items of the
budget and funding appropriations having
amendments having arguments
resuscitating the power the purse
I think something more them don't quote
me on this number but I think something
over that half of our members in the
House Republican caucus haven't gone
through this process before so by having
an agreement which keeps the power of
the purse back in Congress and has what
we call you know appropriations numbers
we're actually going through and
exercising the power of the purse this
gives us more leverage to get better
things with the Senate in negotiations
with respect to riders with respect to
policies within how government agencies
function and what their budget levels
are that to me was the most important
thing that we achieved there did it cut
spending nearly enough now I wanted to
add a few zeros to it you know but but
it what it did was it got Congress back
in the game of doing its job and
exercising the power of the purse
Congressman Ryan
me and my piercer young people are very
concerned about the fact that Social
Security will most likely under current
projections not be there for us when we
reach that age however far too many of
my peers are actually wildly supportive
of large government programs why do you
think that is and what can be done about
it or Hillsdale yeah so at your age I'm
your college I take it graduate school
you're between you're probably around 0%
rate of return on your FICA taxes
um maybe one percent rate of return my
kids are negative one percent rate of
return on our FICA taxes you would
probably do better stuffing your money
of your FICA taxes in your mattress for
the rest of your life than putting in
Social Security so the system is on its
way to insolvency when we run out in
2033 you have a 25% across-the-board
benefit cut and that's if Social
Security can even keep the rest of it
going and so we need to fix this program
I've always believed that we had to let
people keep some of their own money in
an account just like members of Congress
having a thrift savings plan so that you
can earn it so you can own it in it's
part of your property that to me is
something that is far more in keeping
with self-government which is give you
the ability to get a better rate of
return and by the way if you pass away
it's your money goes to your family you
know make it part of your property which
it right now is not so I think there are
some important reforms to make it
solvent so that it's there when you
retire so you can count on it and also
make it more part of your own personal
property so to me those are that's the
kind of act that I think we ought to be
doing which is showing it up making sure
it you can meet its finances and
improved for the next generations who
the younger you are the worst you do in
the system
Thank You congressman Karl Karl call
'van article 1 section 10 no State shall
make anything but gold and silver coin a
tender in payment of debt the founders
realized the power of an inflating
depreciating paper unit of credit to
steal the wealth of the laboring class
Andrew Jackson when the end of the
second bank of the United States said we
were intended to have a circulating
money of gold and silver coin to prevent
the wealth of the laboring class from
being inflated away by the largest
corporations working together with
political interests after World War Two
Bretton Woods was imposed or created to
bring stability to international
relationships do we need to restore an
honest unit of account gold and silver
coins a circulation and a new Bretton
Woods Agreement between the nations to
do away with the petro dollar as just an
engine of conflict yes so this is a
question where what does a prudent
statesman do given where we are and
where we want to go and where we've been
we need a sound money policy they're
putting Fiat back and fiat money these
days I can tell you the Hat I mean look
at what the Federal Reserve has done I
would go back in rewrite or repeal and
rewrite the humphrey-hawkins law and get
the Federal Reserve focused on sound
monetary policy a monetary rule and
having some kind of an anchor so that we
have a more reliable predictable
currency that to me is a very important
prudential step in the right direction
toward getting towards sound money going
all the way to say a gold center or
something like that
i don't know that i don't think that you
could get there right now from where we
are the question is can we put ourselves
back on the road of sound money and look
there's nothing more insidious a
government can do to its people than to
debase its currency and what that is
what I would argue QE whatever number
we're at now 3/4 forever does that so I
do believe that the federal government
the Federal Reserve is way beyond the
Charter it ought to be guising under I
think we should purge all this Phillips
curve dogma from the
Reserve and from their Charter I think
we get the Federal Reserve out of the
regulatory business they're becoming
less independent more political and and
yes audit but also give them a rule that
that that is gives us predictability and
transparency so we know what they're
doing that to me our would be enormous
steps in the right direction toward
restoring confidence in our currency and
restoring sound money
hi glory Taylor I'm actually a political
science and economics my major at Furman
in Greenville South Carolina and we took
a class last semester on labor economics
and we discussed labor force
participation rate as a means of you
know registering right connected that to
different models of government policies
some which created incentive to stay out
of labor force and then you have the
Earned Income Tax Credit that does the
exact opposite so I think my question is
what other policies can conservatives be
advocating for that you know our means
of the government actually promoting
getting back into the workforce and
becoming independent it's a fantastic
question I plan on having a lot more to
say about this next week but I guess I'd
take your question and change a little
bit what can the federal government do
what can the federal government do to
remove the barriers that are in front of
people that make it harder to get into
work Obamacare is a perfect example even
the Congressional Budget Office gave us
this long study that showed millions of
people will be induced to stay out of
the work force because of Obamacare
you take that incentive or disincentive
effect to work whether it's subsidies
whether it's the way our welfare system
works or other regulatory and tax
barriers and you're gonna get up you
gotta remove those so you make it easier
for a person to go to work you know who
pays the highest marginal income tax
rates these days it's not air Rogers you
know it's it's not Warren Buffett it's
it's it's it's the single mom with a
couple kids who makes $40,000 who's
trying to transition from welfare to
work you know in some cases she'll pay
an 80 cent percent marginal tax rate
effectively because she'll lose more
benefits than she gains by going to work
and getting on the path of upward
mobility so we need to deal with that
and that to me it's it's that's part of
the problem why we have a poverty trap
that's trapping people in poverty and so
so I guess I'll have a lot more to say
about this in the very near future but
what we ought to do is systematically go
through the government's approach which
it were the 50th anniversary of the war
on poverty poverty rates have basically
held the same deep poverty is the
highest since we've been measuring it
and look at what the federal government
is doing that's counterproductive that's
actually backfiring and inducing people
to stay out of the work force a job is
the key bridge
our life and so we got to remove those
obstacles smooth those pathways and then
in my opinion help revitalize civil
society so that the connections between
human beings can be more made so that we
can help assist and get people on the
better path I think it's a it's a
multi-faceted effort but it first starts
with getting the government out of the
business of doing harm
congressman Ryan the free market is all
is often criticized as based on avarice
greed and the rest of it and we
recognize that it promotes
self-governance and liberty but can we
not also make the case that it's
actually based on voluntary trade
cooperation and charity instead of
avarice it's charity because labor has
made it's a question I guess but labor
should be satisfying their employers and
companies have to satisfy their
customers voluntarily so that the whole
paradigm really should be flipped what
and what are your thoughts which
compared you know the free market
economy to a competition like a sports
competition where one person loses and
one person wins that is it is not a
zero-sum game it's dynamic it's organic
people gain mutually you can grow the
pie and so I think this language that's
been used probably inadvertently making
it about competition is language that
feeds into this stereotype that it's a
zero sum gain of winners and losers and
the government needs to be involved to
make sure that the pie is sliced up
equally what really free market
economics is really about collaboration
about cooperation about people engaging
in mutual benefit helping one another
pleasing customers satisfying the needs
of other people in serving each other
that to me is one of them where the big
mistakes of the paradigm of free-market
economics you can go to Henry Hazlitt
and all these great people have written
so many beautiful things about how the
free market works
I think we
unfortunately bought into a ditch bought
into a dead end of paradigm and we have
to get back to defending the free market
for what it really is and it's it's
moral absolutes and it's attributes that
make it truly the best possible system
to organize people it's the system that
has done more to help the poor and help
people rise in any other economic system
ever designed we should be proud of it
we should be happy about it when we
should be proud to stand up and champion
it and I think part of it I totally
agree with that is to change our
language so that people understand
really what it is and what it is not
hello sir um in this day and age the
word com compromised his next god
godliness at what point in time do we
take some people think that when do we
start to take it instead of being us
always giving half of what we of giving
the Liberals half of what they want next
year we come back we they want the same
thing again we give them half again when
do we turn that on its edge and make
them start to compromise and move
towards us what I worry about is that I
don't want to make sure that we're just
a reactionary movement that see fighting
things or fighting the other side we
have to rededicate ourselves to the core
to the conservative touch down to our
principles these great founding
principles which are timeless and more
relevant and needed today than ever
before and so when we act in government
we have to be mindful of these
principles and we have to act prudently
in applying those principles what
prudence means to me isn't always go
slow take incremental steps sometimes
you have to do that but it also means
when you have an opening take big steps
you know and we have problems coming in
this country which will require that
kind of prudent prudence as well so to
me compromise is so long as it's in
conformity in advancement of these
principles of our North Star of our
guide is a good thing if it is just
simply splitting the difference with
no tethered to the principals then it's
just as you described he asked me a
question about the the Murray the deal
idea with patty Murray until the
eleventh hour at the last minute they
were holding out for a big tax increase
we had to walk away and say no we're not
gonna do that we're gonna have excess
excessive spending cuts and that
spending cuts and that's the only way
we're gonna do this we're not gonna do a
tax increase so to me I had a principle
in my mind which I wasn't going to go
with I wanted to establish a precedent
that whenever we have these fiscal
problems in divided government we cut
more than we spend and we'd go in reform
entitlement programs which is the driver
of our debt so we don't just shift money
around and do a bunch of the various
budget gimmicks that are out there we do
entitlement reforms and entitlement
savings and those exceed anything else
we do and we don't do it by asking more
from hardworking taxpayers that to me
was the principle I was trying to
advance I made sure that I didn't cross
that line I didn't cross that line and I
was able to get an agreement not a real
big one but I was able to get an
agreement that was in fulfillment of
those principles albeit it was a step in
the right direction wasn't a leap in the
right direction that's the way I look at
these things
which is number one we've got to make
the case to the country these are the
kinds of elections we have to have in my
judgment I think you know the hourglass
has been turned and the sands are going
and we've got I don't know a half a
dozen years before we get solidified
into a very dangerous trajectory in this
country where we basically become a
European type social democracy with a
welfare state and we stagnate we lose
our Liberty our freedom our
self-government and we have a big
administrative state that does what I
discussed in my speech so what does that
mean that means we have to go to the
country and ask the country for
permission to reassert these principles
and more importantly show them what it
looks like in practice we don't like the
direction America is going we think it's
bad for everybody we think it's trapping
people in poverty we think it's creating
economic stagnation we think it's making
us weaker as a country as a people and
we don't want to go that direction okay
what do we do then here are our
principles this is what we believe in
it's the great beautiful founding
principles that made us
in the first place and here are the
policies that flow from those principles
and here's what they look like at the
end of the day and oh by the way if you
vote for us and elect us this is our
contract this is our covenant this is
what we'll do we need those kinds of
elections so that we get the moral
authority and the mandate to do that
after winning an election because like I
said we don't have a lot of time left
that's just the way I see it
thank you for being here mr. chairman my
name is Bennett Hamm palos I am a rising
senior at NYU which you can imagine it's
a very liberal institution some of my
progressive friends often tell me that
President Obama was re-elected on a
popular mandate and and that includes
Obamacare as opposed to the romney-ryan
campaign which essentially ran on
premium support performing Medicare and
everything that comes with your budget
how do you respond to those people who
say that you know a popular majority
voted for Obama and therefore voted to
expand and actually keep the entitlement
that is Obamacare well they also the
people gave us the House Republicans in
2010 and right after Obamacare passed to
try and say stop I think we had a status
quo election basically which froze the
playing field where it was and where it
is again Doe quote me to the math but I
think MIT and I have won the senior vote
by like 20 points and we ran on premium
support look my mom and I were doing
town hall meetings all around Florida
you know talking about premium support
how it works
I really believe here's the other issue
people in the 2012 election heard what
Obamacare was going to be from Obama
before it actually became effective
before it was implemented so yes it was
the rhetoric of Obamacare it was the
theory of big government and all the
trappings and all the great rhetoric
that was used to sell it if you like
your doctor you can keep it it's gonna
lower your health care premiums by
$2,500 it's gonna shore up Medicare it's
gonna do all these great things
so yes an election was run on that
platform and and and they prevailed but
they delayed the implementation of law
until 2013
here comes 2013 and now look where we
are you know broken promise after broken
promise at the broken promise they're
turning Medicare into a piggy bank for
Obamacare they putting this board a 15
bureaucrats in charge of it oh and by
the way if they don't assemble this
board this year which they're supposed
to do one person Kathleen Sebelius gets
to decide how to run the thing so talk
about progressivism
and so what I think now is we the
rubbers hittin the road and the rhetoric
looks nothing like the results and so I
think we've got big government in
practice now whereas in 2012 we had it
in theory that was one of the challenges
made and I had when we were sort of
shadowboxing against the theory of big
government the rhetoric used to sell it
but now people in 13 and 14 see it in
practice and it looks a whole lot
different than the sales pitch so I
think the next two elections are gonna
be more candid elections which is what
this stuff really is what it really
means so that people have a very clear
sense of it our job our objective our
challenge is not just hate it and oppose
it and go against it it's to say what we
would do differently and what I'm trying
to say is we need to be not only an
alternative party in a proposition party
but we have to show how we all govern
what principles we use what's our
disposition so that the country knows
what they're getting you know we can't
just listen to a bunch of pollsters and
a bunch of focus groups to tell people
what we think they want to hear we've
got to say here's what we think we need
to do to save the country these are the
principles of how we're gonna apply them
here's what it looks like and then if we
lose that election we lose that election
but as far as I'm concerned I think
we'll win that election but as far as
I'm concerned I think it's the only way
to fix this thanks everybody
appreciate it thank you
thank you thank you for those wonderful
remarks and I want you know you're
always welcome here at the Kirby Center
of course and and on the main campus of
Hillsdale anytime and to where at that
occasion we have a Hillsdale ty for you
nice you also have good taste and I let
me pick up the color
I let him pick out first thank you for
you before your marks and on behalf of
the college like to thank you for your
service to the nation and especially
today I'd like to thank you for
upholding and defending the principles
our beloved country so thank you very
much thank you thank you all for coming